it definitely can and i think the  eurozone has taken some very significant  steps in the right direction most  importantly Mario Draghi the head of the  European Central Bank has taken steps  but also given direction and plan but  it's not going to be easy and what I've  been emphasizing is that because it's  going to take time to focus on fiscal  and structural reforms helping countries  like Spain and Italy be able to get  reasonable financing until the benefits  of those reforms take effect and fixing  the banking system that the critical  issue will be the politics reforms and  being able to sustain this effort over a  number of years and while i think  europeans are committed this is the  difficult challenges of miscalculations  maneuvering room and external events  that could make it harder for them to  stay on the path they'd like to pursue  you